hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys i'm
andrew so andrew and i today and by the
way andrew just started up a youtube
channel guys you guys have been wanting
him to do one for a while now and now he
has one going does a lot of movie talk
today we're gonna review Star Wars or
Star Wars Episode four new hope it's
such a good movie it's a great [ __ ]
film we're gonna review the original
trilogy we're not gonna do the prequels
we'll get it to that wide a little bit
later I mean starting off with this
movie watching it again was amazing
because right when it says Star Wars
because I haven't seen the movie in
years so when it says Star Wars at the
beginning it's like wow I can only
imagine being in the theaters and being
introduced to this film with the awesome
prologue or that at how the credits
scroll and then we get our introduction
into these characters and what I like
about the film I didn't notice before is
that it's kind of like a build up movie
it starts off on a rather small scale
like after Darth Vader they get to
tattooing and then it's like a rather
really small scale but then as each
scene goes it gets bigger and bigger and
bigger and by the finale it's just huge
you know I just love how basically in
the first two minutes we we already know
what's going on for the most part in the
story you see the rebel ship you see the
Imperial ship and you see if they're
chasing them and they want something
they have it's basically laid out in a
platter in the first two minutes and
with that exposition having to be you
know splattered into our face I mean we
can just see the visuals and already
tell what's going on I feel it's such a
good you know plot element story on them
when you can just show something
visually and you already know what's
going on without having to you know like
I said spoil it and say exposition all
over the place and tell us what's going
on so I thought that was a very good way
of just introducing us getting us right
into the world when you see the first
shot you see that small rebel ship and
that hue yeah period like yeah they are
in a lot of trouble right yeah I'd love
that opening right there and I mean just
like you said every scene gets bigger
and bigger and bigger and we learn more
about this world and how big you know
the universe and galaxy is it's just
such a great journey on this trip and
the characters are so well written in
this film yes it really does make you go
what
the characters are so well rated in this
film that I think what really makes this
movie stand the test of time is this
awesome group of characters because
everyone sort of introduced as an
individual no one's really tight-knit
and by the end of this film you got a
really strong group of unlikely heroes
oh yeah what's great about it is the
second you see these characters you get
these characters when Darth Vader
appears more than just his outfit you're
just like the way he walks like I own
the [ __ ] room and then you hear James
Earl Jones's voice and you're like this
guy is [ __ ] scary yeah and Leia you
know she's the leader of the rebels cuz
the prologue her very second moment we
see of her she shoots at a stormtrooper
you're seen like oh she's a fighter you
know she's not just some like woman
who's giving orders like she's in the
field the damsel in distress she's
actually a warrior as as well as a
princess no I agree with you and also on
top of that as well as the amazing
characters the arcs in this film for
each character is fantastic just to see
where Luke starts off at the beginning
of the film see where he ends up at the
end see where Han Solo has that
scoundrel awesome scoundrel I got me
wrong but you know that character arc II
has at the end you know which we'll go
into once we you know discuss go into
detail on each scene but just again the
character arcs in this film are amazing
the characters are amazing and just
instantly they're very likeable right
off the bat it's you know what I mean
you understand their motivations and
what what they're after immediately it
doesn't waste time you know fill er up
fill er up it just tells us immediately
what they want han Solo all he's
interested is in money Luke Skywalker he
just wants to join the rebellion yeah
wait Leia she wants to destroy the
Imperial base Darth Vader he wants the
Death Star plans it's very simple it's
not over complicated it's a very simple
plot and very likeable characters you
know it's funny about the acting in this
film is it's not like the best act in
however the characters are so memorable
like with Luke Skywalker I'm watching
him like three camels a little over the
top here he's still so [ __ ] likable
like he's the most likable dude on the
planet where's Iping why are you seeing
a movie directed by George Clooney
yeah the best acting in it no we're not
saying they're bad performances at all
they're great performances still but I
completely agree you can tell a few
scenes there is like like the power like
the compare converter
that was a little over the top I like
that they did show that though because
it shows against a character arc for him
he starts off as a kid who's like you
know a little whiny and kind of like
Anakin in episode two but you know what
I mean but you see that character arc
and you don't mind that moment because
you see where the character goes at the
ends those kind of moments don't bother
me like you said because of where we see
where they end up and they do pull it
off great performances despite not the
best direction in the world so I can
only agree with you one thing I really
loved is what they did with c-3po and
r2d2 I love their dynamics about c-3po
always treats him like he doesn't like
him but then when r2d2 is in any type of
danger he's like so concerns for his
life and he's overdramatic all the time
he's a worrier and then r2d2 is like you
can't you don't know what he says yet
you're like r2d2 is that [ __ ] like you
knows that I handle things I love that
they brought these droids really to life
and the characters don't treat them like
hey you're just droids they treat them
like they're people they can communicate
with you know I love that level of
humanity and respect to their machines
not another story of oh the droids are
gonna take over some [ __ ] you know of
course no I completely agree and also
that had what you're saying I love that
they there's so many scenes in the film
where the droids are the heroes for
instance that scene where r2d2 saves
them in the trash compactor that was a
big scene any scenes were you know c-3po
was interpreting for them you know it
basically takes the plot or story to the
next scene so they're not just there to
be there they're very important and
essential of the plot and also they have
a huge part to play as well as you know
having their own heroes scenes which I
love and that one scene where as c-3po
is telling the stormtrooper that the
right that there they went that way or
something yeah it's just like it's like
he's not he's not a human but he does
have a little bit of a brain I guess he
has a heart you know yeah it's cool it's
like he cares but they don't talk about
like the engineering that went into that
I like how they just make you accept
that any enough I completely agree
what's interesting about this film is
its light on humor but when all these
characters come together there's a lot
of humor
obi-wan Kenobi now what uh what a legend
you know like he's in one of the Star
Wars movies alive you know he's in the
other two as good as a ghost but force
ghost I like that he's in one of these
movies alive he's just
[ __ ] memorable you know he's the wise
he's like he's like David Carradine from
kungfu but you know like a Jedi
completely agree that I mean that bar
scene where you just chop that guy yeah
that just he means business and he's on
the man and I told you I'm not huge
heavy into so many exposition scenes but
when he's laying down exposition about
the Clone Wars and giving Luke his
lightsaber it's so intriguing and I've
just loved hearing that stuff so and you
know he why he has such a passion for
this even though he's been kind of like
in exit exile it's because they
established a he trained Darth Vader
it's cool to have like that be the
protagonist but he also constantly
thinks in the bigger picture of things
he's the definition of a wise character
and how can we not talk about this movie
without mentioning the force the horse I
never quite comprehended just how
beautiful the concept of the force is
it's everything I'd like time to get a
little personal it's everything I
personally believe about life that
everything is energy attraction and that
we limit ourselves with our own brain
thought and like I totally believe
people are so capable of love levitating
something the thing is the reason I
can't do it I'm not at the level yet
where I believe I can actually do that
but if some like I've heard stories of
like those monks with the cold towels
and then it goes like sweaty hot and
when they're in a freezer like weird
[ __ ] the force capitalizes on that idea
of the universe all and we're all in
connection and we're more than capable
of everything so follow your heart
because your instincts are telling you
more than what your brain might talk you
out of that was deep that's what's up
Ryan right people I can't really add
much more than that but I will just say
just just watching the scenes where they
where you see Luke to learn a little bit
I mean again we don't dive too deep into
the force in this one which I love -
keeping them out a real mystery but just
that one scene where he's you know
blocking with the laser with the with
the lightsaber with the block with the
oh yeah I love that scene where I guess
Han Solo says you know he doesn't
believe in hope
your religions and stuff like that just
a great scene and where we really get an
idea just again we're still left a
little mystified with just this film we
don't have a full understanding of the
force just that little hint of it where
he's you you know and also up obviously
the last scene in the Battle of Yavin
where 1000 to take off the targeting
system is the force it's so powerful I
mean again visual you don't need to do
exposition to tell us stuff you can
visually show us and we will understand
we are somewhat smart yeah exactly so
when the characters come together with
Han Solo Han Solo comes in rather late
into this film for such a memorable
character you're like I also came here a
little way yeah and Han Solo you know
Harrison Ford's performance only
Harrison Ford can do what Harrison Ford
does he manages to immediately make a
guy likable who was such a dick at the
end of his day and I think what saves
him what causes a saving grace is the
fact that his best friend his partner is
Chewbacca because he doesn't treat you
Baca like you're my pet in order my
slave like he communicates with
Chewbacca yeah he's the leader you know
what I mean he treats him like a human
being
yes but it's his best friend it's his
best friend and the fact that he's so
bonded with someone who he can't even
speak the same language it well it does
one of those things where like he
understands what he's saying but I love
how they do that by the way where Chewie
you know speed or does his growl and
then Han just says what he's saying we
understand we don't need to see
subtitles or whatever saying we
understand just from Wow Han reacts to
him they're best friends and we feel
that bond instantly it's not like oh you
treats him like a pet or that's his like
as dog friend or something no you can
tell the connection immediately they're
best friends and they would they would
take a laser for each other right now
and you instantly fill that bond
instantly so I completely agree with you
love that bonding connection between all
the characters especially Han and Chewie
you know there's the famous scene like I
guess they're spoilers in this review
there's this is gonna be a spoiler did
you have not seen this film yet sorry 77
guys one thing I gotta get the prequels
without talking too much about it real
fast is they updated the hell out of the
Jedi fights mmm-hmm you know like that's
one thing those prequels got right was
they made the Jedi fights a lot cooler
and it's interesting to see the first
Wars Jedi lightsaber fight it's just
them like poking at each other it's more
like sex it's like a dance
yeah choreograph at first when I saw
this film I remember having a hard time
getting on board with obi-wan being a
ghost but it goes so in line with the
force that were more than just our human
bodies you know he gets struck down and
that's a sad moment and it does affect
Lucan it puts Luke in a situation where
he is completely alone right now Luke
Skywalker as an interesting arc because
it doesn't do that thing where he kills
someone and then he's like oh my god
this is what it feels like when he
starts killing people he's like yeah so
Luke is actually a serial killer people
he has a mass-murdering in person inside
of him thousands of people in that dead
zone
yeah I know even he kills people on that
deaths like that one famousy where he's
like shoots down a TIE fighter he's like
okay last thing I want to talk about the
finale yeah oh the Battle of Yavin to
this day it's amazing how this film had
barely any budget it's from the 70s
still holds uh still holds up like
really strong I know you're not making
exceptions when you're watching that
show I completely the practical effects
of miniatures and all that yeah look
massive when you're watching I agree and
sometimes when I watch that battle I
have to relook at the box on IMDB just
to confirm it was made in 1977 because I
can't believe how good it still holds up
it's incredible it's choreographed well
it's intense it's exciting intent
there's so much tape you really feel
even even though you might have an idea
that Luke might sort you you feel
there's so much attention with Darth
Vader starts getting out start shooting
and every yeah I mean just everyone
plows basically most of the ships on
there and you have a real deep concern
for Luke in that scene until you know
our hero saves the day oh hamsa and now
it's cool oh oh it's awesome love how
they didn't like really set that up okay
you can kind of predict especially with
movies nowadays of everything we've been
exposed to we can predict that console
is probably gonna come in and save the
day
however this film does it in such a way
where you're so engrossed in the battle
so engrossed in the moment between Luke
and Vader that you forget that Han Solo
is gonna chill I'm sick of the day also
I feel like if they were doing it today
starwars maybe if it's the Batman V
Superman trailer people I feel like they
would have shown that in the trailer on
save me I'm like oh okay there's no more
tension in this film now you know like
you just said last thing for me when
Darth Vader's about to shoot Luke you're
not even thinking anymore about Han
you're just so unconcerned for Luke and
then boom you say is they like wow such
a great hero moment such a great
character arc for Hogg because at the
beginning the film there's no way he
would have came back for Luke right
there no way they had a built up
friendship that you truly felt and you
believed that he would come back for him
in that moment at the beginning of him
there's no way ya came back for him and
with Han Solo with the ceremony you see
this guy's changed you know he was
always a loner wanting to be on his own
he has now joined the rebellion like he
has a purpose in life now he has a cause
everything's written to so well
characters come together fully love the
sequences of spectacle and everything
like that fantastic film apparently
people don't understand movie reviews
unless there's a rating so I'm gonna
make one up right now I give it five out
of five
lightsaber dildos
I will concur with that and give it five
out of five - anyway guys listen thanks
for tuning in to the channel if you're
new to it click this button today
subscribe and become a reject and andrew
has a channel now - like we mentioned
earlier youtube.com slash movie source
check it out Andrew talking about movies
and you can tell he knows what he's
talking about follow us on our social
networks Andrew tweets a lot I Instagram
a lot and I'm also now on you now the
live streaming thing yes where you can
donate to me it's a good app let's get
out